SAROS GETS THE CALL FOR JOHANSE-
OFF.
CARRIER GAVE IT AWAY,
GOOD READ.
MARCHESSAUAL IN HIS LAST 13.
AND NOW NASHVILLE END. WEST
TONIGHT.
LA AND ARIZONA ON THE VGK.
>> Shane: A GOOD PASS BY
ALEXANDER CAREY ON KARLSSON
LEADS IT
ROMAN JOSI.
>> Shane: A BIG SAVE BY ACROSS.
EKHOLM STRAIGHTAWAY AND OUT THI
A GOOD START  ON THAT SHOT.
FIRST SHOT GETS
RUN WIN.
4-1-1 IN THE GOOD FEED BY GRANL
FORSBERG. GOT TIPPED
PUCK.
THEODORE WITH OPEN OFFENSIVE
ZONE.
BENNING AND THIS
PUCK COMES AROUND.
KARLSSON BACK TO THEODORE
>>> PREDATORS UP ORS MAKE IT NO
A ROW SUCCESSFULLY KILLED. OVER
HUTTONBLOCKED FOR
THE PREDATORS BUT A GREAT
CHANCE.
THIS PUCK IS JUST GOING BY FORS
FORSBERG FINDS HIS WAY TO THE
NECK, BACK CAN'T SCORE.
A BEAUTIFUL MOVE BY FILIP
FORSBERGTO
HIMSELF.
AND THEN TO
WILLIAM KARLSSON OUT HIGH.
WHITECLOUD THROWS IT TOWARDS
THE NET.  SSON OFF
THE PILE.
HE WILL PICK UP THIS REBOUND.
QUICK SHOT RIGHT BACK AT WRISTI
PULLS IT OUT AND SCORES.
I THINK THERE WAS S FIRES.
JEANNOT BLOCKS THAT ONE. OF THE
IT GOES OFF HIS GAIT.
REILLY SMITH BATTLING FO
THIS GAME A LITTLE CLOSER.
STEPHENSON,  THEODORE.
PIETRANGELO  DOWN TO LONG-RANGE
YOU CAN SEE JANMARK IN FRONPIET
THEODORE THOUGHT ABOUT SHOOTING
IT AND NOW